TUCKER, THAN IF HE HAD NEVER
BEEN BORN.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU.
THE STANDING QUESTION IS, IS
FLORIDA PREPARED FOR
SELF-GOVERNMENT?
MEANWHILE ERIC EGGERS CONDUCTED
A LOT OF RESEARCH WITH THE
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
INSTITUTE.
HE'S THE AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK,
"FRAUD, HOW THE LEFT PLANS TO
STEAL THE ELECTION."
THAT BOOK ACTUALLY CONTAINS A
SECTION ON BRENDA SNIPES.
THE VERY PRESENT ERIC EGGERS
JOINS US TONIGHT.
SO BRENDA SNIPES' POSITION IS
SHE'S BEING UNFAIRLY ATTACKED AS
A PERSON.
WHY DO YOU THINK SHE'S BEING
ATTACKED?
>> I THINK SHE'S NOT VERY GOOD
AT HER JOB, TUCKER.
THAT WOULD SEEM TO BE ANOTHER
THING THAT MS. SNIPES IS NOT
VERY GOOD AT COUNTING BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY HER TRACK RECORD
IS LITTERED WITH MISSTEPS AND
VIOLATIONS OF THE LAW.
IN 2018, IN THIS ELECTION, WE
KNOW THAT ILLEGAL BALLOTS WILL
COUNT IN THE GOVERNOR'S RACE AND
SENATE RACE BECAUSE THEY WERE
INCAPABLE OF CLEANLY SEPARATING
ILLEGAL BALLOTS AND LEGAL
BALLOTS ONCE THEY HAVE BEEN
OPENED FROM THEIR ENVELOPES.
IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME AND SHE
HAS ADMITTED UNDER OATH THAT SHE
HAS ALLOWED ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
AND FELONS TO CAST BALLOTS IN
BROWARD COUNTY IN VIOLATION OF
NUMEROUS LAWS.
YOU MENTIONED THE TIME SHE
DESTROYED THE BALLOTS THAT SEEM
TO HAVE GIVEN A BOOST TO DEBBIE
WASSERMAN SCHULTZ.
HER OFFICE HAS BEEN FOUND GUILTY
OF OPENING BALLOTS ILLEGALLY AND
WITHOUT PROFIT, PROPER OVERSIGH
OVERSIGHT.
WHY IS THE OPENING BALANCE --
BALLOTS -- HER QUOTE WAS I GUESS
I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE MEANING
OF THE WORD CANVASSING.
SO IT OFFERS NOT VERY GOOD
THINGS FOR FLORIDA.
>> Tucker: IT SO WHY WOULD
THIS BE A CONCERN OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT?
THIS IS A FEDERAL ELECTION AND
WE HAVE A VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
>> THAT'S A QUESTION THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE ASKED.
HOW IN THE WORLD IS THIS WOMAN
STILL IN OFFICE.
BUT PEOPLE I THINK HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN AFRAID TO
CHALLENGE DR. SNIPES, QUITE
HONESTLY BECAUSE OF WHAT YOU
MENTIONED.
THEY ARE AFRAID OF BEING
CHALLENGED AND CALLED A RACIST.
WHEN THE BRENDA SNIPES' COUNTY
OFFICE ATTORNEY PUSH FORWARD AND
SHE WAS BEING CRITICIZED BECAUSE
SHE DONATED TO POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS, AND ACTUALLY ONE OF
THE COUNTY COMMISSIONERS WHO WAS
ON THE OPPOSING END OF ONE OF
THE CAMPAIGNS, THE
BROWARD COUNTY ATTORNEY DONATED
TWO, THE ELECTIONS COUNTY
ATTORNEY PLAYED THE RACE CARD
AND TRY TO RALLY SUPPORT BY
GENERATING A BUNCH OF
AFRICAN-AMERICAN ATTORNEYS TO
SHOW UP IN SOLIDARITY.
8 OF 9 WERE DEMOCRATS AND QUITE
HONESTLY, YOU DON'T DO VERY WELL
AS A POLITICAL OFFICIAL IN
BROWARD COUNTY IF YOU ATTACK
AFRICAN-AMERICAN DEMOCRATS, EVEN
THOUGH RICK SCOTT IS A
REPUBLICAN, HE OBVIOUSLY HAD
STATEWIDE ASPIRATIONS, HOW DO
YOU YOU THINK HE WOULD DO IN
FLORIDA IF YOU ARE PERCEIVED AS
A RACIST?
>> Tucker: THIS IS HOW
DEMOCRACY DIES.
ADMITTING IN PUBLIC SHE'S
BREAKING THE LAW AND NO ONE CAN
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT?
WHY IS THAT NOT AN ACTUAL THREAT
TO DEMOCRACY?
>> I THINK THE LARGER THREAT TO
BE HONEST IS SHE HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT SHE IS NOT
VERY GOOD AT COUNTING VOTES.
HOW DO YOU THINK SHE'S BEEN AT
PREVENTING ILLEGAL VOTES FROM
ACTUALLY BEING CAST?
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS AN EFFORT
TO MANIPULATE THIS ELECTION
THROUGH ILLEGAL VOTING.
THERE WERE 108 ATTEMPTS TO
REDOUBLE VOTES IN MIAMI-DADE
WHICH MEANS PEOPLE TRY TO CAST A
SECOND BALLOT IN THE SAME
ELECTION.
ATTORNEYS FOR BILL NELSON AND
ANDREW GILLUM HAVE BEEN
CRITICIZED BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
OBJECTED TO THE REMOVAL OR
EXCLUSION OF NO NONCITIZEN VOTES
IN PALM BEACH COUNTY.
SO MY CONCERN, WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO SAY ABOUT THESE 83,000
BALLOTS THAT SHOWED UP AFTER
ELECTION NIGHT, WHAT CONFIDENCE
LEVEL DO WE HAVE ABOUT THE
BALLOTS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CAST AND WHERE THEY CAST BY
LEGAL VOTERS?
>> Tucker: THAT'S EXACTLY